bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte on
vous propose aujourd'hui un dossier sur
les nouvelles habitudes alimentaires des
habitudes qui change dans certains cas
très vite des produits qu'on n'aurait
jamais pensé manger il ya quelques
années à peine sont désormais facilement
accessibles à l'épicerie
mais pour que cvg burger et autres
yougos en produits laitiers soient
disponibles il faut que toute
l'industrie agroalimentaire s'adapte
voyez d'abord comment ces nouvelles
tendances se dessinent au chant
[Musique]
le milieu agroalimentaire et celui de la
restauration sont un peu à l'image de la
ville de québec les classiques côtoient
est de plus en plus la nouveauté comme
dans le vieux québec où gastronomie
vegan est végétarienne se taille une
place dans le paysage
c'est vaut avoir des yeux sans partage
je vous dirais pas que c'est vraiment un
choix comme seul donneur manger dans un
restaurant comme ça mais c'est quelqu'un
qui ne le fait découvrir puis c'est très
bon jusqu'à
[Musique]
ce nouveau marché centré sur la protéine
végétale est en plein essor
ici comme dans bien des grandes villes
c'est l'importance et les savoirs les
gens ils trouvent que c'est ça vaut rôle
ils vont venir je pense c'est pas une
question de rejouer absolument marche
populaire dans mon assiette pour ça
c'est vraiment que les gens trouvent
sont bons c'est ça le secret je pense
l'engouement pour les aliments à base de
végétaux frappe même là où la galette de
viande a toujours régné dans le secteur
de la restauration rapide
les ventes de burgers sans viande
explose la protéine végétale emballe
même les marchés boursiers l'intérêt
pour la protéine végétale n'ai vraiment
aucune mode passagère mais va s'inscrire
dans le temps long transformer la
société l'alimentation le de manière
durable
de plus en plus les consommateurs sont
soucieux de leur santé mais aussi de
l'impact environnemental du contenu de
leur assiette
il délaisse peu à peu la cuisine
traditionnelle tournée vers la viande au
profit d'une alimentation plus variée
pois chiches soya lentilles et haricots
se retrouvent plus souvent au menu de
nouvelles habitudes alimentaires en voie
de transformer le paysage agricole
[Musique]
ce nouvel élan pour la protéine végétale
profite à cette entreprise familiale de
saint-émile de sorel en montérégie est
vraiment un engouement autant sur le
marché local que l'on desservait mais le
ja on voit le les commandes augmentent
[Musique]
harry beck s'est lancé dans le commerce
des légumineuses il y a trente ans bien
avant l'arrivée sur le marché des
substituts de viande
l'entreprise vend la quasi totalité de
la production québécoise et
commercialise plusieurs variétés
[Musique]
présentement la demande pour les
légumineuses bondi
les gens sont curieux puis on va
vraiment à voir apparaître de plus en
plus de produits aussi qu'ils vont être
transformés à base des légumineuses
ça arrive de partout présentement
les chiffres témoignent de cette
effervescence en 2018 2019 au canada les
ventes de substituts de viande
représentait 7% de l'ensemble des ventes
de protéines dans le commerce au détail
une croissance annuelle phénoménal de
35%
il est temps d'y cacher chapitre de
cette histoire depuis sept décennies
notre pays a énormément changé au début
de l'année 2019
le nouveau guide alimentaire canadien
vient lui aussi souffler sur la braise
en recommandant de faire une plus grande
place aux aliments protéinés d'origine
végétale ils sont désormais élevé au
même rang que la protéine animale
[Musique]
tous
chez harry bec avec la saison des
récoltes qui achève la chaîne de
production tournent à plein régime
c'est immense sac de haricots sont
destinés à des clients de la région des
balkans et du bassin de la méditerranée
là où les légumineuses sont au coeur des
traditions alimentaires
mais l'entreprise doit aussi satisfaire
la demande grandissante du marché local
[Musique]
revenez dans cinq ans puis ce soir qu'on
aura beaucoup d'autres produits à
démontrer donc ce n'est que le début je
pense du règne de la protéine végétale
québec
mais ce n'est pas encore la révolution
dans les champs au québec la production
des légumineuses demeure stable
jean grande nuit a été un pionnier en se
lançant dans la culture de légumineuses
il y a une vingtaine d'années il produit
des haricots sur une centaine d'hectares
j'ai déjà fait deux il est d'abord
introduit les légumineuses dans sa
rotation pour améliorer les rendements
de ces autres cultures
les légumineuses capte l'azoté de l'air
et le fixe dans le sol la culture
suivante peut ainsi profiter de cet
apport en engrais azotés jean grog a
aussi l'intimé conviction de pratiquer
une agriculture plus respectueuse de
l'environnement la culture des
légumineuses est peu gourmande en eau et
elle émet moins de gaz à effet de serre
que la production de viande faut la
nourrir la planète classe et puis je
trouvais les légumineuses culture guise
fait venir je l'introduit au printemps
la récolte à l'automne qui est prête sur
la table parce que si on mange du porc
du poulet peu importe là c'est ça prend
ça prend d'autres cultures
en sortant du maïs 36 ans prend du blé
pour nourrir ses animaux leur
aujourd'hui une cargaison de haricots
rouges par à destination de lusine de
harib est située à moins d'une heure de
route de la serm le producteur et le
transformateur travaille en étroite
collaboration pour produire et mettre en
marché des haricots haut de gamme donc
on commence à voir des partenariats
d'affaires comme ça où un des
producteurs et des transformateurs ont
l'un et l'autre en fait gérer leurs
risques
on voit là qu'on est capable d'apporter
une valeur ajoutée à un produit qui a
été longtemps être au québec c'est plus
la soupe aux pois les favoris
pendant des décennies c'est
principalement dans les cabanes à sucre
que les québécois ont consommé les
légumineuses daniel dubé de la ferme le
prieur à saint jean port joli nourrit
maintenant l'ambition de réinventer la
place du poison dans notre assiette
moi j'ai sondé le marché des acheteurs
potentiels dans le monde bio et c'est là
j'ai vu qu'elle vienne pénurie cet
ancien producteur de lait s'est converti
à la culture du poison biologique en
convaincu de l'immense potentiel et des
avantages de cette légumineuse que le
projet en étant aussi une culture courte
on peut le faire sur une culture
d'automne serré à l'automne et c'est
très propre et si on voit très bien les
bel effet de la part d'aso du poids dans
la course suivante
pour transformer sa récolte en produits
à valeur ajoutée
il fait moudre seppois au moulin de
saint-roch-des-aulnaies la municipalité
voisine
[Musique]
le résultat une farine qui a de
nombreuses vertus sur le plan
nutritionnel et qui remplace facilement
la farine régulière
[Musique]
daniel dupuis croit que le point jaune
pourrait devenir le produit emblématique
de la région la région de saint jean
port joli avec son climat frais se prête
bien à cette culture
la croissance des pois jaunes rapide est
parfaite pour la courte saison et
d'autres producteurs biologiques des
environs se montrent intéressés par
cette légumineuse nous on est capable de
s'ajuster à la demande puis on est
capable aussi des crayères réseau
régional des producteurs bio qui ne
demandent que à nous approvisionner mais
dans l'ensemble la culture des
légumineuses reste marginal au québec
moins de 2% des terres agricoles de la
province sont consacrés à cette
production
les changements s'opèrent bien
timidement
[Musique]
la recherche et développement doit se
faire et chez terra donc toute une
filière qui doit se déployer
on commence à voir les signes de ces
changements le haut pays
c'est dans les prairies que se trouve le
coeur de la production de légumineuses
en saskatchewan particulièrement
la province produit plus de 75% des
légumineuses canadienne 90% de sa
production est exportée
[Musique]
et le géant de l'industrie ne ménage
aucun effort pour profiter des nouveaux
débouchés qu'offrent les protéines
végétales
ce